eads ne veut plus investir dans sa
filiale cassidian tests et services les
400 salariés concernés basé sur le site
d'elancourt toulouse et castrés ont
manifesté ce lundi l'enjeu s'opposer au
projet de cession de leur entreprise un
investisseur les syndicats estiment
qu'avec 85 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires en 2011 la société est en
bonne santé
ce projet fait un choix un choix
politique
voilà de la déesse de se séparer de de
tester services ias qu'aucun choix que
industriel qui est sous-tendu f1 aucun
choix
financiers on voit pas l'avenir de
tester service de son emploi de tous les
atouts industriels il peut se faire dans
eads et non pas avec un
partenaire dont
on connaît tous vraiment pas l'avenir 1
les deux qui nous ont annoncé au départ
dans mahindra l'indien mahindra de
l'autre alyotech vraiment c'est on va
vers des incertitudes assez grande voilà
donc nous on pense que notre avenir est
la garantie de notre avenir se situe
dans eads
avec des conditions d'investissement
on se tient complètement notre directeur
dans cette dans cette direction
d'investir pour des veaux produits
investir en r&d et en démarche
commerciale
cassidian tester service s'occupe des
bancs de test pour des équipements
aéronautiques et compte comme clients
les compagnies aériennes des industriels
comme thales et dassault ou encore le
ministère de la défense le repreneur
devrait être connu fin juin début
juillet d'ici là les salariés restent
mobilisés